foreign
Texas starting this hour Hey Thomas
what's up
hey y'all thank you so much for taking
my phone call I appreciate it our
pleasure how can we help
well um so we just started the program
my wife and I we've been married for
about five years and we've just been
struggling paycheck to paycheck
obviously
and um we just kind of got fed up with
it we had the aha moment like what are
we doing we keep
um uh just making some some some tough
decisions and
um we went started detecting the
experience and stuff like that started
finding like who we have our um our
outstanding debt with and turns out you
know I have about 11 600 in debt which
wasn't that much compared to some of the
cars that you have on the phone so we
were really aesthetic about that then we
got to my wife's side of things and it
turns out she's about 153 000 in debt
and it wasn't something that I was
really aware of from the get-go and
um um it's kind of a unique situation
000 of it is into a mortgage that her
name is on but
um in the divorce decree that she had
with her previous husband she signed any
kind of uh all that over to him
um now she did that on the intentions of
some sort of verbal agreement that he
had with her that she he was going to
pay her out or give or buy her out with
a certain amount of money
um we've been waiting for about five
years like I said since we've been
married and we haven't seen any sort of
dime in order from that and that's this
huge debt hanging over our head and I'm
wondering does the divorce decree give
her half ownership in the house no she
signed it over
so why was he why is he obligated to buy
her out
well it was um now they have a kid
together and she lives with us and we've
been taking care of you know all of that
and yeah why is he obligated to buy her
out of the house when the divorce decree
didn't say that
he's not
um he's not obligated but as I said had
a verbal agreement and they're they are
um there are they're unspeaking terms
it's not like they're it's a divorce
decree state that he had to refinance
the house and get it out of her name
um no it did not
um but that's what he's saying that he's
gonna do
um but it just happened but he's under
no legal obligation to do anything
pretty much no
so he doesn't have to I mean if he wants
to sell the house and give her half when
the time comes that's his prerogative
but he doesn't have to be in a rush
because this wasn't and he doesn't have
to refinance yeah
no no court no judge decreed this
right and that's what that's where the
problem lies and I'm wondering
um so what's the status who lives in the
house
we actually do you live in a house that
someone else owns that's our ex-husband
correct interesting
tell me about it
uh okay that's awkward yeah that's that
feels messy
I mean like I said their relationship is
fairly decent to have a kid together
that's very um civil it's not like
they're eight patients with each other
he tries to pay child support
he he is supposed to he's not very good
about it but he's been better yes what's
the house worth
um it's probably worth about 300. how
old are the kids
um she's 17.
are you I have a question about the
mortgage are you paying the actual
mortgage or are you paying a different
amount uh
we pay we pay like we paid pretty good
compared to rent prices around here we
pay 1300 a month whether that covers the
mortgage payment I'm not sure but I'm
sure it probably covers
most of it if not all of it okay so
Thomas here here's um this is messy for
everyone
it's messy for him it's messy for your
wife it's awkward for you it's even
messy for their daughter
so
um he's got another year of child
support due he's been on a he's been
unwilling or unable to pay that there's
a hundred and fifty thousand or so in
equity that he has on a handshake said
he was going to share but I'm not sure
how good his memory is because he
doesn't pay child support
regularly like he should
okay
um
and I'm not sure how good his memory is
on refinancing and so probably the only
card you all hold is uh two cards you
have a persuasion card
for your wife and maybe you're in the
room I don't know the dynamic but sit
down with him in person and say oh this
is all real messy and with her getting
ready to turn 18
um we need to clean this up
okay so our uh we're gonna move
and when you sell the house
um we're willing to work with you on the
back child support and the missed child
support payments if you
um honor your word on getting the house
sold and on splitting it with me if
you're not going to do that then we're
going to go to court over the back child
support payments because we're going to
at least collect that
and you're gonna you're gonna sell the
house but I think you in other words I
think you can just free in a friendly
way just say it's time for us to put a
bow on this mess
that's a bad one put put up uh pin in it
put a pin in it yeah put a pin in this
mess that's better and uh the best way
to do that is to get uh get us off we're
on a mortgage together we don't need to
be there this you got this child support
hanging over your head if you'll split
the house with us like you said you
would and go ahead and get it sold and
get the mortgage gone and we get half
the equity well for no child support
from here on out you're out of child
support for the rest of the year and for
any back child support we're not going
to bother you about it but let's go
ahead and get this done let's get this
cleaned up because it's time for
everybody to go their own way it should
have been done five years ago the
attorney that these two people used was
an absolute
I don't think they use an attorney I
think they just went through this stage
so yeah I rushed my case yeah they were
absolute more on jail there's a horrible
transaction
poorly designed everything about it was
not thought through they all thought
we're going to be friends we're going to
be friends you might end up friends
that'd be nice it'd be great if you do
I'm not trying to pick a fight but you
need to wrap this up because there's
just so much electricity in the air
asking for an explosion with child
support not hitting but you can't really
call him on it because you're not sure
he's going to keep his word on getting
the house out of her name and whether
he's going to keep his word on splitting
the house with her because he doesn't
really have to because we didn't really
put it in the divorce decree because
nobody was driving this bus as it went
off the cliff
yeah and we're not even really worried
about the child support to be honest
with you we live on our own income
that's my point so get you know use that
as leverage because you don't need it
let him out of it and that's your give
if he'll go ahead and split and go ahead
and get the house sold and get the
mortgage out of your wife's name
okay if he doesn't do all of that you're
probably going to have to hire an
attorney and force this because it's
what should happen it's Gotta you gotta
get this cleaned up you may never get
half the equity that's possible but at
least get the mortgage out of her name
because you guys aren't gonna be able to
buy a house moving forward till you get
this mortgage out of her name
uh messy messy boys and girls if you're
going to go through a divorce do not
give the person the ownership of the
house and stay on the mortgage quit
claim deed and stay on the mortgage dumb
lazy strategy don't do that